hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I mentioned a
question from one of my facebook fans
Josephine who wrote in saying my biggest
problem at the moment I want to start a
business my biggest problem is how to
have a conversation with my boss but my
resignation and he likes to be highly
appreciated I wrote back to say why is
it hard to have the conversation and she
wrote saying because it's hard because
my boss takes things personally and will
give me a hard time as I prepare to
leave so thanks for the question
Josephine congratulations on being
willing to take that step a lot of
people are stuck in a job that they hate
they don't look forward to going to they
may not like their boss or coworkers or
they feel there's no growth in what
they're doing and they want to start a
business but they just don't have the
guts to actually go out and do it and so
congratulations of being already at that
stage for be willing to chase your
dreams create your own destiny
unfortunately there are you know some
hardships that come along with what
starting the business and this will be
one of them you know having that
conversation with your boss I think I
think for you to get started it's
figuring out how much loyalty do you
have to your boss you know you do you
appreciate the work that he or she has
given you and the opportunity Pat over
the past X number of years you've been
working there and if so you want to try
to give them the as much opportunity as
possible to find the replacement and be
available you know as much as possible
I've had people who have you know left
my business and going on to do other
things and it's great for them right you
want to be able to follow your passion
you don't want somebody working at your
business who doesn't want to be there
and you know they've always given me
notice and enough time to be able to go
out and find somebody else to help out
except in one case and maybe I'll share
that story a little later the one guy
anyway
so if you can give them you know give
your boss notice be available after that
time even just to answer questions to
help train the new person be as open as
you can and that helps soften the blow
any any good boss should a try to keep
you if they think you're a good worker
and they like you or be if they
recognize that this is just not going to
be for you that it's limiting
I you know whatever job you're at and
you want to go off and explore your
potential any really good boss should be
should be happy for you should be
welcoming of the opportunity for you to
go off and do something else as long as
you're giving them the opportunity to
find somebody new and and be be there be
available to help train and be involved
in that transition process even
afterwards you know after your two weeks
notice or whatever it is you're going to
give if you have that conversation and
it doesn't go well or you don't like
your boss oh you're just dying to get
out of there this is an opportunity for
you to start making the tough decision
you know you have to start building some
character you're going to have a lot of
challenges as you grow your business
it's it's hard to start a business it's
not an easy thing to do it's hard to get
off the ground it's hard to get past
that survival stage we have enough money
to to you know pay your bills and feed
your family and you're going to have a
lot of difficult conversations that
you're going to have to stretch and and
learn from and so this is maybe your
first one and if he's not willing to be
supportive of you then you know you
might have a rough couple weeks for that
last time that you're going to be there
but I would just try to keep in mind the
opportunity that you have ahead of you
and the excitement that you're going to
have and starting your own business and
hopefully that fuels you through and
it's it's a good learning opportunity
for you because you're going to have a
lot more tough decisions and hard
gut-wrenching choices you're going to
have to make that will push you beyond
your comfort zone because that's what
being an entrepreneur is all about so
thank you for the question good luck as
you start on your journey and if you
have more questions about it feel free
to leave more questions and I'll try to
answer you as you go along your path so
for everybody watching please give the
video a thumbs up if you liked it and
I'd love seeing those coming and always
think's going to do more and if you have
a question about this video or question
about your own business I'd love to
answer for you if you want to leave it
in the comment section below so thank
you and I'll see you on the next episode
you
you